the message from Iran's nuclear official
could not have been less subtle standing
next to a heavy water reactor Mets have
been filled with concrete after the
nuclear deal we made it clear it can
easily be put back into use again then
at a press conference the same official
warned Europeans time is running out to
save the entire agreement the Europeans
still have some time left they of course
had the whole of last year which we
labeled from our side the year of
strategic patience they had a further
two months after the year had passed in
10 days the Iranians say they'll have
enough low-grade enriched uranium to be
in breach of the nuclear deal the Trump
administration pulled out of a year ago
despite that US officials are condemning
Iran we continue to call on the Iranian
regime not to obtain a nuclear weapon to
abide by their commitments to the
international community and I think you
know it's unfortunate that they've made
this announcement today as I said
earlier doesn't surprise anybody I think
this is why the president has often said
that the jcpoa needs to be replaced with
a with a new and better deal just when
we thought the tensions caused by last
week's tank attacks might have been
subsided Iran is upping the ante the UK
says it believes Iran was to blame
Britain's Minister for the Middle East
told MPs that was unacceptable I think
it would be wrong not to record our deep
disquiet of the destabilizing actions of
the Iranian administration it is using
proxies quite clearly to destabilize the
region Germany's foreign minister
meeting his European counterparts in
Luxembourg was also worried for the
chances of escalation how did he lag and
a fierce war
with extreme explosive I still think the
situation is extremely explosive
military confrontation in the Gulf would
mean that the whole region would be on
fire nobody can be interested in that
there is some time for Europe and Iran
to save the deal but the countdown has
begun to a showdown between the Trump
administration and Iran with uncertain
consequences Dominik Waghorn Sky News